[Music]
in black widow we play a family of spies
back together again
so today we're going to test ourselves
with a little game two truths
and a lie here we go one of the first
movies i ever acted in was home loan
three
i once passed out from eating a ghost
pepper the hottest chili pepper in the
world
i once appeared in a music video with
bob dylan oh is there even a home alone
three that can't be true you're not it's
true
i wasn't home alone what i never passed
out from eating a ghost oh i held it
together did you
i'm strong i can do the splits
true i acted in two shakespeare
adaptions
no from the ages of 12 to 14 i was a
competitive skateboarder
i do not believe you were a competitive
skateboarder
i touch it and i'm like whoa oh my god
future's in one lie i once got kicked in
the face
by denzel washington i briefly worked as
a krav maga
instructor i never swim in the ocean
because it terrifies me uh you're not
afraid no way you're a krav maga
instructor briefly no
you see my krav maga tactics you missed
it
it's all elbows i knew it it's so cool
right